au lendemain des attentats alors que la
vie a repris presque normalement à
londres le réseau des bus et du métro
fonctionnent comme chaque jour le bilan
des victimes a été revu à la hausse une
cinquantaine de morts 350 blessés
toujours hospitalisés 22 dans un état
critique
sans compter les possibles victimes
toujours enfouis sous les décombres
du côté de l'enquète la piste d'al-qaïda
est largement privilégiée l'hypothèse
des kamikazes semble exclue les banques
deux mois 2,5 kg placés dans des sacs
aurait provoqué les explosions la police
qui fait appel à tous les témoins
possibles
une enquête qui s'annonce complexe et
difficile en france le plan vigipirate
est au rouge le contrôle aux frontières
transmanche a été notamment renforcée
patrouiller dans les gares les aéroports
et autour des sites touristiques
un dispositif d' alerte renforcée
également en italie et aux etats unis
sur la route les départs en week-end
chargé avec aujourd'hui une journée
rouge en ile-de-france et demain dans
tout le pays des bouchauds prévu sur les
routes du sud en particulier
et puis les collections haute couture
automne hiver 2005 2006 aujourd'hui jean
paul gut et ses silhouettes inspirées
des pays de l'est contrairement au luxe
orientale su christian lacroix madame
monsieur bonsoir la vie continue coûte
que coûte depuis hier les anglais
montrent un réel sens froide dans
l'épreuve
une volonté de résister de ne pas se
laisser impressionner par les
terroristes aujourd'hui à londres dans
une ville peut être plus calme qu'à
l'ordinaire
chacun a retrouvé ses activités les
banlieusards et ceux du centre ville ont
repris le bus le métro partant au
travail comme n'importe quel vendredi ou
presque et ces images sans doute que
l'on retiendra au lendemain de ces
attentats qui ont fait une cinquantaine
de victimes maryse burgot et mareuil
dominique marault tel sur place au coeur
de la city un homme d'affaires pressé il
vient de sortir du métro
pas question de se laisser impressionner
par les terroristes
il faut continuer on n'a pas le choix
bien sûr les gens sont un peu plus
nerveux mais de toute façon ce n'est pas
la première fois que nous subissons des
actes terroristes à londres
dans le métro les visages sont certes
tendu mais les rames sont parfois bondé
les journaux font leur une sur les
disparus
et parce que les anglais ne se départit
jamais de leur humour certains se
détendre lisant quelques vieux articles
sur la victoire de londres pour
organiser les jeux olympiques c'est un
drôle de sentiment de s'asseoir
aujourd'hui dans le métro
c'est triste mais je ne me sens pas
menacé
je ne crois pas que la foudre frappe
deux fois au même endroit
donc je suis confiant on doit continuer
on ne peut pas laisser ces terroristes
influencé notre vie il faut aller de
l'avant
les londoniens qui veulent à tout prix
éviter le bus ou le métro se sont rués
sur les deux roues entre hier et
aujourd'hui les magasins de vélos ont
été dévalisés ce jeune homme met toutes
ses économies dans une nouvelle
bicyclette
oui je crois qu'après ce qui s'est passé
hier on peut vraiment passé au vélo en
plus c'est plus écologique et c'est une
bonne excuse pour dépenser une telle
somme dans les bus à impériale les
usagers sont moins nombreux que
d'habitude mais là non plus il n'est pas
question de se laisser aller au
pessimisme
moi je fais tout pour ne pas penser à
ces terroristes
en fait je me concentre sur mon travail
et sur ce trajet dans une ambiance bien
particulière les londoniens ont donc
décidé de défier les terroristes à leur
façon en se remettant au travail dès
aujourd'hui une certaine fébrilité
malgré tout avec quelques évacuations
notamment à la gare de houston dans le
centre de la ville puis ce sont des
stations de métro qui ont été fermées
après des alertes à la bombe
on est vigilant parfois nerveux sur le
qui vive une série kurt et devant le
british muséum de valise cadenassée à la
grille d'entrée
aussitôt l'alerté donnée les agents sur
place pour évacuer des touristes plus
curieux qu'inquiet mais les policiers
traitent tous les colis suspect de la
même façon les démineurs interviennent
ici pour rien un peu partout la même
scène se répète
notamment dans les gares de la capitale
mais poussés londonien qui utilisent
quotidiennement ces transports
les réactions sont un peu différentes
ils avaient un qi très vite sans
discuter
le coeur serré oui bien sûr on construit
ça ce qu'il s'est passé hier
mais je crois que les gens ne doivent
pas changer leurs habitudes
sinon ce sont eux qui gagnent je ne vais
pas changer ma façon de vivre à cause de
ces gens là par tous les moyens les
londoniens tente d'apaiser la tension
mais beaucoup ne sont pas venus
travailler craignant une paralysie des
transports
le maire ken livingstone lui qui est un
discours de combat
je sais que vous allez échoué dans votre
objectif de détruire notre société libre
et je peux vous montrer pourquoi vous
allez échoué dans les jours qui viennent
et à y regarder nos aéroports
regardez nos ports regardez nos gars et
nous avoir lâchement attaqué vous allez
voir que les gens de notre pays
les gens du monde entier viendront à
londres pour devenir londonien
concrétiser leur rêve et révéler leurs
talents et partout dans la ville les
gestes de solidarité se multiplient
toutes les religions ensemble nuit pour
rejeter ceux qui tenteraient de les
diviser les quatre attentats à la bombe
selon un dernier bilan ont fait une
cinquantaine de morts -selon compte
désormais les 13 victimes de l'attentât
survenu dans le bus près de russell
square ce bilan pourrait encore évoluer
car des corps sont toujours enfouis sous
les décombres et des familles plus de 24
heures après les attentats sont encore à
la recherche de leurs proches
un français restent introuvables
frédéric protat matière secondes
ils sont épuisés d'avoir parcouru des
kilomètres dans les rues de londres
adrien et sébastien sont sans nouvelles
de leurs amis slimane avec qui il
partage depuis peu leur appartement
quinze jours qui l'avait cloué et voilà
il a disparu tout simplement n'avait
aucun doute qu'un autre moyen que la
vôtre ok non non a dit sont bien passées
par l'ambassade mais l'ambassade ils
font ils font leur travail de leur côté
quoi et nous on va pas rester les bras
croisés comme ça rien faire on a baissé
les femmes pour des épreuves même en
boîte pour ta vie dans ses mains une
photo de laura sa soeur dont il est sans
nouvelles hier matin il profite de la
les âges de tous les médias pour se
donner toutes les chances de la
retrouver
je ne sais vraiment pas si elles se
trouvaient dans le bus dans le métro y
va et je suis sûre il n'y a aucune
nouvelle d'elle dans les hôpitaux
il était dans le bus si vous avez vu
appelez moi ils sont comme cela des
dizaines regroupés près des lieux des
explosions
ils sont prêts à tout pour obtenir la
moindre information qui pourrait encore
leur donner l'espoir avec cependant la
crainte d'apprendre le pire
côté français l'ambassade qui a monté
une cellule de crise reçoit des
centaines d'appels
certaines personnes sont relativement
inquiet elles ont essayé de joindre
rhj toute la journée ils n'arrivent pas
à avoir de l'information
donc on sent de l'inquiétude les
recherches continuent inlassablement
pour tenter de retrouver ces personnes
disparues une bonne partie des victimes
se trouvant encore coincés dans les
rames du métro et leur identification
devrait prendre beaucoup de temps
les hôpitaux londoniens sans surcharger
ils font face à l'afflux des blessés qui
ont été transportés hier tout de suite
après les attentats vers plusieurs
établissements de la ville sur les 700
blessés 350 sont encore hospitalisés je
vous le dise en titre 22 personnes ce
soir sauf dans un état critique la
famille royale a tenu à exprimer toute
sa compassion et sa solidarité
aujourd'hui
camia et le prince charles puis la reine
elizabeth ii se sont rendus au chevet
des victimes elisabeth 2 qui a déclaré
que les terroristes ne changerons pas
notre mode de vie
lens bastia dire sa compassion aux
victimes des attentats hospitalisés aux
saintes maries hospital c'est ce qu'a
tenu à faire le couple princier dès ce
matin dès leur arrivée le prince charles
et son épouse camilla ont d'abord
exprimé toute leur admiration aux
sauveteurs et aux personnels
hospitaliers puis charms seront au
chevet des blessés
s'excusant de les déranger j'ai pris le
métro pendant des années sans jamais
avoir peur et voilà ça s'est produit
vous veniez juste de monter dans la rame
oui oui on venait de passer dragoon le
prince charles s'est aussi détendre
l'atmosphère
je crois bien je vous ai vu à la
télévision c'est l'impression que j'ai
je ne sais pas les ti vous pas en train
de marcher oui je marchais attentif
chaleureux le prince écoute le récit de
l'horreur il y avait un officier il a
escaladé le métro derrière et à veiller
sur moi pendant une heure et demie trois
hommes nous rassurait sans arrêt il me
faisait parler de mes enfants
la reine elizabeth elle aussi a rendu
visite aux blessés à l'hôpital royal de
londres avant de s'exprimer
je veux dire toute mon admiration aux
citoyens de notre capitale et après les
attentats à la bombe d'hier calmement
déterminé à reprendre une vie normale
c'est notre réponse à cet outrage un
discours de fermeté très applaudi par
des onglets sous le choc mais déterminés
à ne pas céder à la peur revenons à
présent sur le film des événements
quatre bombes à l'heure de pointe hier
matin ont explosé en l'espace de
cinquante six minutes en plein centre de
londres touchant trois rames de métro et
un autobus les images dont nous
disposons sont rares elles proviennent
des téléphones portables de troisième
génération qui ont permis à des
passagers qui se trouvaient là de filmer
quelques secondes comme son père londres
hier matin il est 9h47
la dernière explosion vient de retentir
la cible le bus numéro 30 près du square
de thalys com
ces images sont tournées par un pass
nous découvrent plusieurs passagers du
bus projetée sur le sol
quelques policiers tentent d'apporter
les premiers soins
selon les premiers témoignages le bus
était rempli de passagers
la bombe se trouvait apparemment à
l'étagé supérieur
et puis chez moi à travers la fenêtre
j'ai vu le bus il y avait énormément de
fumée décor le toit du véhicule avait
été projetée à terre
j'ai regardé quelques secondes entendu
les gens crier et je suis descendu
immédiatement près des blessés
l'explosion était extrêmement violente
les passagers à l étage supérieur ont
été déchiquetés et les secours ont dû
travailler dans des conditions très
difficiles
les urgences depuis six mois et là en
trois heures j'ai vu la même chose qu
ancien le bus numéro 30
la quatrième explosion en moins d'une
heure la première a eu lieu à 8h51 dans
une station de métro dans le quartier de
la city
la deuxième cinq minutes plus tard
toujours dans une station de métro
la troisième à 9h17 toujours dans le
métro mais cette fois ci à l'ouest et
une demi-heure plus tard le bus numéro
quatre explosions dans des lieux
différents dans un délai très court une
tâche très difficile pour les secours
à 8h51 la première explosion toucha
mettront entre deux stations en plein
dans un tunnel
cette mort le deuxième attentat a eu
lieu près de la station de king's cross
cette fois ci la bombe se trouvait dans
la première voiture sur plusieurs
documents amateur filmée par des
passagers on est frappés par le calme
avec lequel les londoniens quittent les
lieux du drame
moi j'étais dans la voiture de tête pas
très loin de la cabine du conducteur
on entendu un énorme bang à l'extérieur
de la station métro les gens
s'entraident immédiatement comme cet
homme que l'on voit ici près d'une femme
blessée
un homme qui fait aujourd'hui la une de
toute la presse et qui devant les
journalistes expliquent qu'ils se
rappellent seulement du prénom de cette
femme et elle s'appelle davinia à
l'heure actuelle les secours ont encore
le plus grand mal pour accéder aux
wagons d'explosion une partie du tunnel
du métro menace de s'effondrer
à 9h17 au nord ouest cette fois ci se
produit la troisième explosion toujours
dans le métro le train venait à peine de
quitter la station
enfin à 9h47 le bus numéro 30
après des recherches très difficile les
autorités ont pu annoncer cet après midi
qu'il y avait qu ici 13 morts quatre
explosions total une série d'attentats
sans précédent pour la grande bretagne
pour les autorités britanniques la
marque d'al qaïda est évidente même si
les enquêteurs ne disposent d'aucune
preuve aucune certitude et ce soir il ya
davantage de questions que de réponses
sur le mode opératoire des terroristes
sur leur identité
il pourrait être d'ailleurs susceptible
de recommencer car la police semble
écartée jusqu'à preuve du contraire la
piste des kamikazes scotland yard qui
lancent des appels à témoin
reconnaissant que l'enquêté sera longue
et complexe
audrey goutard trouvé lundi celui qui
permettra de tirer un fil vers les
auteurs des attentats vers ceux qui ont
placé leurs explosifs dans le métro et
dans ce bus des charges suffisamment
puissante pour provoquer de tels dégâts
et faire tant de victimes
les enquêteurs savent maintenant que les
terroristes ont utilisé un explosif
militaire du plastique une charge légère
mais très puissante elle tient dans un
sac storage à ce stade de l'enquêté nous
sommes convaincus que chacun des engins
utilisés dans le métro était
probablement déposés à même le sol des
vagues en ce qui concerne le bus de
tavistock skweres il est aussi possible
que l'engin était sur le sol que sur un
siège
pour le moment dans les décombres les
policiers n'ont trouvé aucune trace de
détonateur ni deux minutes heure aucun
système de mise à feu
mais il reste prudent ils n'ont pas pu
encore accéder à tous les décombres à
moins que les terroristes ne se soit
fait exploser eux mêmes en plus des
premiers indices matériels
les policiers de scotland yard ont déjà
dans le collimateur un homme d'origine
pakistanaise
ils ont identifié aujourd'hui en
épluchant les listings passagers de
l'aéroport de heathrow leur suspect déjà
connu des service antiterroriste est
arrivé deux jours avant le drame avec un
billet simple sans retour juste une
piste parmi d'autres
rien de plus pour l'instant mais pour
scotland yard toute information est
précieuse
nous avons absolument besoin des
témoignages du public dans de pareilles
circonstances ces témoignages recoupés
peuvent nous fournir la troupe ce qui
fera la différence
les policiers britanniques le savent
déjà
à moins d'un coup de chance l'enquète
s'annonce longue et difficile
nous retrouvons et laurent boussier en
direct de scotland yard avec ce début de
polémique qui laisse à penser que les
services de sécurité anglais ont baissé
la garde
considérant en fait peut-être que la
menace terroriste était moins présente
ces dernières semaines vous avez
béatrice et dès qu'il ya un drame il ya
des gens qui cherchent la polémique il
faut savoir que en grande bretagne seul
le aim high five c'est à dire les
services de renseignements intérieurs
l'équivalent de notre dst est habilité à
élever ou abaissé le niveau d'alerté
terroriste il le fait selon des
informations propres ou selon des
informations qui proviennent de scotland
yard
or depuis plus d'un mois et demi en fait
depuis les coups de filets de scotland
yard justement dans les milieux
islamistes il n'y avait plus
d'information plus d'éléments qui
permettait de penser à un acte
terroriste imminente
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que maintenir
un niveau d'alerté élevé coûte très cher
très cher en sommes très cher matériel
très cher en argent
d'où la décision somme toute logique de
baisser ce niveau d' alerte au début du
mois de juin
vous savez la crise en matière de
terrorisme il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
la faillibilité récemment aujourd'hui
même la patronne la directrice via my
fab expliqué que cet attentat était venu
de nulle part et qu'il n'y avait aucun
signe avant coureur
merci
en mousse et de ces précisions la ville
de l'andrh vous le savez une capitale
cosmopolite où cohabitent de nombreuses
communautés toutes ont condamné
unanimement ces attentats la grande
bretagne compte un million et demi de
musulmans et les fidèles ont prié
aujourd'hui pour les victimes dans
toutes les mosquées du pays l'islam est
la deuxième religion du royaume uni les
musulmans qui ont été invités à aider
les autorités par tous les moyens un
appel lancé jusque dans les mosquées les
plus radicales comme celle de finsbury
park où se sont rendus arnauld miguet
edwards père un vendredi jour de la
grande prière pour les musulmans
la mosquée de finsbury park jadis entre
du land de nice temps et ancien repère
d'abou hamza a fait peau neuve
et aujourd'hui les policiers ne sont pas
venus surveiller les débordements de
l'imam radical mais plutôt pour protéger
la communauté d'acteurs revanchard dans
cette petite mosquée à quelques mètres
de là on affiche la couleur avec un
message clair les musulmans sont unis
contre le terrorisme
sourate du coran à la pure depuis les
attentats londonien la communauté de
nouveau montré du doigt on est désolé
pour hier ça ne peut pas être des
musulmans qui ont fait ça c'est
contraire à notre religion nous
musulmans nous voulons aider les
services de sécurité pour trouver ceux
qui ont perpétré ces crimes soient
disant au nom de l'islam dans ce
quartier connu sous le nom de petit
algérie à cause du nombre important de
nord africains
on craint encore une fois qu'on confonde
islam et terrorisme
d'autant que pour hocine des musulmans
aussi ont été frappés la station qui
s'appelle organisme
c'est une communauté musulmans du
bangladesh qui habite là-bas et je suis
sûr à 100% qui doit y avoir une majorité
aussi à des victimes c'est les musulmans
les musulmans doublement touché entre
condamnation est malaisé visant à biskri
parc ancien fief fondamentalistes
certains réflexes perdure même si la
communauté musulmane a immédiatement
réagi pour condamner les attentats
elle craint toujours les amalgames et
les représailles
voyons maintenant comment la communauté
française a vécu cette journée deux à
trois cent mille français travaillent à
londres et ce vendredi ils sont
retournés à leurs activités
un rythme presque normale yann fronty
elle a préféré marcher dans les rues de
londres
plutôt que de prendre le métro même s'il
a plu elle n'a pas voulu utiliser le
réseau souterrain trop de crainte ce
matin samir a donc mis deux heures pour
rejoindre son travail au lieu des 40
minutes habituelles
aujourd'hui je regardais les gens
rentraient dans le métro sortir je
pouvais pas donc j'ai attendu le bus
j'ai marché enfants wanda et val de
saures installé à londres depuis 8 ans
n'ont pas eu de problèmes de transport
ce matin elle habite à quelques mètres
de leur boutique dans le quartier chic
de notting hill
aujourd'hui même si les clients ont été
rares elles ont repris le travail
la journée d'hier a été difficile mais
c'est de joindre actions de gens la
possibilité de téléphone je sais que mes
parents étaient très inquiets
heureusement on a pu communiquer par
internet
je sentis très isolé parce que je
prépare la personne en fait pas question
de faire une pause
herman gêne aussi a repris le travail
lui aussi hier pourtant il a échappé au
pire
une bombe a explosé à quelques mètres de
lui aujourd'hui
première femme qui crie n'est pas
quelque chose qui se passe c'est clair
tout le monde d'être relax
londres compte près de 250 mille
français c'est l'une des communautés
étrangères les plus importantes à
l'image des autres habitants de la ville
il compte désormais reprendre une vie
normale
celle qui était la leur avant les
attentats ont joué 10 juillet les
touristes envahissent londres ils
étaient nombreux hier dans le centre de
la capitale à se retrouver bloqués par
les attentats des touristes qui en
général on fait comme les londoniens ne
rien changer leurs programmes et guy
leroy josé boulesteix
elle en a connu des bombes et pourtant
la tour de big ben sommes toujours aussi
bien l an ce n'est pas quelques
attentats de plus qui décourageront les
touristes de la ville en espagne on a
l'habitude des attaques terroristes
vous savez c'est comme ça et on s'y fait
après elle a peur d'une nouvelle attaque
d'une autre attaque à la bombe
confiné dans les hôtels hier les
touristes sont ressortis timidement
aujourd'hui à piccadilly circus
les visiteurs tentaient de reprendre le
cours de leurs vacances on ne prend pas
le métro on ne voyage qu'en bus on a eu
un peu peur on a pris le métro dans la
matinée il n'y avait pas grand monde
on a eu un peu peur londres était
complètement bloquée hier les théâtres
ont fermé car personne ne pouvait s'y
rendre aujourd'hui leur ouvrent tous
leurs portes
on est ouverts exactement comme
d'habitude et les choses vont reprendre
leur cours normalement
c'est également le flegme et la force
des londoniens après le choc d'hier que
les touristes voulez admirer aujourd'hui
et même l'essence de l'ordre
omniprésentes
non pas attrister les photos de vacances
il nous vous retrouvons maryse burgot en
direct de londres
on reste tous très impressionnés par
l'incroyable calme ont affiché les
anglais au lendemain de ces attentats
c'est ce que vous avez constaté tout au
long de cette journée
oui vous savez les londoniens ont gardé
le souvenir des attentats perpétrés par
les terroristes de l'ira dans les années
70 à cette époque d etat d attentat a
été commis en permanence dans la
capitale britannique ait une certaine
habitude un certain fatalisme s'était
installé au sein de la population et
bien on peut dire que trente années plus
tard les britanniques semblent avoir
conservé les réflexes acquis à l'époque
beaucoup de sang froid et surtout une
réelle capacité à se remobiliser à se
ressaisir très vite nous les avait vus
ils étaient nombreux dans les métros
dans les bus ils étaient nombreux à les
retravailler aujourd'hui l'économie est
déjà reparti l'amour ça d'ailleurs déjà
digéré cet événement et la plupart des
valeurs ont terminé ce soir à la hausse
merci maryse burgot on le disait dès
hier soir les autorités anglaises ont
pendant longtemps offert un sanctuaire
aux extrémistes islamistes une attitude
pas toujours bien comprise par les pays
européens
et pourtant ce système permettait aux
services de renseignement britanniques
de surveiller de localiser les
plus radicaux c'est ce qu'affirme
aujourd'hui bon nombre de spécialistes
qui regrette le démantèlement de ce
dispositif en big shaq cardoze le
meeting a lieu chaque année sur
trafalgar square
il réunit les partisans de l'islam
radical au grand dam des autorités qui
ne peuvent l'interdire au nom de la
sacro sainte liberté d'expression preuve
que londres n'est plus un sanctuaire en
2002 les policiers interviennent pour la
première fois suite aux prêches
enflammés de cette image un an après le
11 septembre plus question de laisser
faire surveillance accrue contrôle des
cassettes
la méthode est répressive mais elle a
aussi compliqué le travail des services
de renseignement on peut penser que la
politique de répression et le tour de
vis engagées par les autorités
britanniques a provoqué cet effet de
clandestinité finalement des mouvances
et des responsables et que à partir de
là il était beaucoup plus difficile de
contrôler justement les militants qui
avaient perdu leur leader charismatique
leurs idéologues emprisonnés et qui
livrés à eux-mêmes pouvait en soldat
perdu forcément peut-être organiser des
attaques de représailles contre les
autorités
le chef de file des plus radicaux à
londres abou hamza est aujourd'hui
emprisonné dans la tente de son procès
quant à la mosquée de finsbury park où
il officiait elle a fait l'objet de
plusieurs perquisitions à sa réouverture
au printemps dernier c'est une mouvance
plus modérés qui en a pris le contrôle
mais alors où sont passés les plus
radicaux
pratiquement soit en prison soit en
résidence surveillée d'autres ont pris
la fuite
non ce n'est pas mission alors tony
blair a annoncé en mars 2005 le chiffre
de 200 terreau vis sur le sol
britannique pour rendre à la nature mais
les services de sécurité britanniques
étaient beaucoup plus mesurés ayant
annoncé le chiffre de 40 à 50 actifs
dangereux sur le sol britannique
enfin dans ce que l'on appelle le long
de nice temps il y à ces groupes
apparent est politisé mais probablement
moins dangereux car plus facile à
surveiller en france derrière le plan
vigipirate est émise rouge dominique de
villepin annonce aujourd'hui sa volonté
de renforcer les contrôles aux
frontières en particulier sur la
frontière transmanche à paris car
aéroports et sites touristiques sont
placés sous haute surveillance
indeed boudaoud philippe thiébaut et
antonin retard
dans les couloirs du métro parisien pas
d'inquiétude visible pourtant
au lendemain des attentats commis à
londres la vigilance est dans toutes les
têtes
respectivement
des messages sont diffusés régulièrement
la surveillance dans les transports en
commun est une priorité pour les forces
de l'ordre
notre mission c'est ça c'est de
contrôler les personnes suspectes de
détecter tout paquet au niveau des
commandes des rames et puis à
l'intérieur des rames également les
patrouilles sont surtout là afin de
rassurer les usagers eux mêmes déjà
sensibilisés je vois des colis suspect
c'est vrai que ça attire mon attention
quand même plus puisque hier à paris
près de 2000 policiers gendarmes et
militaires sont mobilisés comme dans le
métro
la présence policière est renforcée dans
toutes les gares parisiennes depuis hier
à roissy
les contrôles des personnes et des
bagages sont plus poussés
les vols à destination de la
grande-bretagne et des etats-unis font
l'objet d'une surveillance accrue
aujourd'hui les patrouilles étaient
nombreuses
beaucoup plus rassurés de voir des
policiers un peu partout avec les
événements qui ont eu lieu hier
pour moi mon travail
paris et placé sous haute surveillance
l'armée et la police patrouille temps
semble dans les rues de la capitale 250
points sensibles sont protégés parmi
lesquels les ambassades de grande
bretagne des états unis ou d'italie les
contrôles des frontières vont aussi se
multiplier
c'est le cas dans le port de calais à
l'embarquement vers l'angleterre et au
terminal du tunnel sous la manche
deux cents hommes seront attendus demain
en renfort les autorités françaises
affirment que l'on n'est pas à l'abri
d'une attaque terroriste est ce qu
indique est chez nous hier nicolas
sarkozy policiers et magistrats
antiterroristes sans avoir reçu de
menaces précises sont préoccupés les
attentats de londres montre bien qu'il
ya des cellules dormantes amaury guibert
c'est une course contre la montre lutter
contre le terrorisme islamiste quand un
réseau ans remplace vite un autre
aujourd'hui selon les services de police
l'une des menaces qui pèsent sur la
france viendrait d'un groupe algérien on
constate plusieurs phénomènes
d'abord du côté du terrorisme chérir le
gspc s'est fait allégeance à la mouvance
al qaïda
le gspc groupe salafiste pour la
prédication et le combat dont voici
l'une des vidéos de propagande née en
1996 en algérie cette organisation
aurait effectivement offert ses services
et demander de l'aide
abou moussab al zarqaoui le chef d'al
qaïda en irak
dans une lettre interceptée par les
services secrets américains
le gspc dénonce aussi la france pour son
soutien au régime algérien une menace
identifiée mais une menace parmi
d'autres car à côté des réseaux
structurés appareil nouvelle génération
de militants plus difficile à cerner ces
jeunes gens qui ne sont pas assainis par
les camps d'al qaïda en afghanistan ni
parlent les autres d'entraînement en
irak qui ne sont pas non plus passer par
la bosnie qui n'ont pas de casier
judiciaire et qui finalement ont été
formés par d'autres d'autres islamistes
radicaux et sur lesquelles on n'a aucune
information
exemple avec cet homme farid benyettou
personnages clés de l'enquêté sur la
filière irakienne il a été initié par
son beau-frère membres du gspc puits
baigné tout est devenu le leader d'un
groupe de jeunes du 19e arrondissement à
paris qui voulait combattre en irak
aujourd'hui les services de
renseignement craignent que certains
d'entre eux de retour en france ne
soient prêts à y commettre les attentats
aux etats unis maintenant le niveau
d'alerté a été relevé les attentats de
londres ravive le traumatisme qu'ont
vécu les américains le 11 septembre dans
les grandes villes les patrouilles se
multiplient à washington la sécurité a
été renforcée auprès de certains
bâtiments stratégiques
alan jara nous sommes tous des
britanniques
au milieu des fleurs devant l'ambassade
de grande bretagne à washington cet
écriteau traduit bien le sentiment des
américains ce qui s'est passé à londres
les touchent particulièrement
l'angleterre c'est un peu le 51e état de
l'union et les liens entre les deux pays
sont si forts ça nous rappelle combien
ils nous ont soutenus dans notre
tragédie à nous après ce que nous avons
vécu nous-mêmes
c'est absolument inacceptable que des
civils soient pris pour cible au hasard
la secrétaire d'état condoleezza rice
est rendue elle aussi à l'ambassade pour
signer le registre de condoléances
ils ne seront pas morts en vain at elle
écrit elle a ordonné aussi dans un geste
inédit que le drapeau britannique
souhaite hisser en berne devant le
département d'état londres 7 juillet new
york 11 septembre
l'analogie est dans tous les esprits
les médias ont repris leurs titres chocs
de l'époque la guerre contre le
terrorisme est à nouveau à l'ordre du
jour le secrétaire à la sécurité
intérieure a décrété le passage du
niveau d' alerte de jaune à orange
risque élevé dans tout le pays
ici à new york la sécurité a été
renforcée dans les transports en commun
et devant les cibles potentielles
la peur et de l'autre en cas d'attaqué
les américains se rassemblent
généralement autour de leur président et
ça devrait faire les affaires de georges
rousse au plus bas dans les sondages
mais ça montre d'un autre côté que sa
stratégie dans la guerre contre le
terrorisme notamment l'irak marque
décidément le pas l'italien engagé aux
côtés des etats-unis en irak est en
alerte rouge c'est ce que titre la
presse d'aujourd'hui dit elle il se sent
menacé
même si rien n'est très visible
aujourd'hui à rome par exemple alors que
silvio berlusconi reconnaissent et hier
au g8 que l'italie est une cible
potentielle reporter gérard dhesse bec
claude guénin
c'était il y à une heure à peine la
ville de rome se recueillait en hommage
aux victimes des attentats de londres
est symboliquement les élus se rendait
en cortège au capitole drapeaux déployés
italien et britannique
l'heure est bien sûr à la solidarité
dans le deuil mais aussi dans le refus
de céder au terrorisme
avant de quitter le g8 pour rome silvio
berlusconi le chef du gouvernement
italien a déclaré qu'il était l'une des
cibles prioritaires des terroristes avec
les deux autres b bush et blair
depuis ce matin les mesures de sécurité
ont été renforcées surtout dans le métro
point faible du dispositif car les lieux
sont très difficiles à surveiller alors
les rondes se succèdent et les romains
sont bien conscients du danger après
l'attentât de madrid on avait un peu
oublié cette menace mais il ne faut pas
avoir peur et aller de l'avant
moi j'ai peur ici nous n'avons pas la
sécurité la police n'est pas présente
moi je ne les voit jamais
au vatican la présence policière est
bien discrète mais paraît-il efficace
des dizaines italiens ont déjà été tués
par des islamistes mais on n'ira jamais
l'italie n'a encore été touchées après
madrid et londres rome sa tante opinion
après la condamnation unanime et d
atlanta hier de nombreux pays en tenue
on l'a dit à montrer leur solidarité
avec la grande-bretagne comme ici à
bruxelles où deux représentants des pays
membres de l'otan ont observé une minute
de silence à la mémoire des victimes
les drapeaux de l'otan également été mis
en berne en espagne les drapeaux des
monuments et des bâtiments officiels ont
également été baissés ce jusqu'à demain
minuit
le gouvernement espagnol qui observaient
cinq minutes de silence pendant le
conseil des ministres aujourd'hui des
minutes de silence qui ont eu lieu
également dans d'autres grandes villes
rappelant le 11 mars 2004 et l'exclusion
de dix bombes dans quatre trains à
madrid attentats qui avaient fait plus
de 190 morts enfin la france a décidé de
mettre ses drapeaux en berne pendant
trois jours en hommage aux victimes des
attentats les drapeaux sur les édifices
publics ont été descendus cet après midi
enfin en écosse le sommet du g8 de
gleneagles s'est achevé ce soir appelant
à de nouvelles mesures contre le
terrorisme international
les dirigeants des pays les plus riches
qui par ailleurs ont tenté d'avancer sur
le dossier du réchauffement climatique
sur unix intelligible francis au rejet
après quelques heures passées à londres
tony blair est revenu hier soir à
gleneagles
il n'y aura pas eu d'interruption du
sommet les cinq chefs d'état africains
ont rejoint ce matin le g8 avec les
représentants du fmi de l'organisation
du commerce de la banque mondiale
l'ordre du jour n'a pas été modifiée
c'est l'aide à l'afrique et la volonté
pour les pays riches de manifester leur
solidarité avec les pays émergents
par contraste avec les violences
terroristes le président de la
république en tête
tous ont signé l'accord qui fait passer
l'aide globale au développement de 25 à
50 milliards de dollars par an d'ici
2010 dont la moitié pour l'afrique
l'europe assure 80% de ses engagements
les américains font un effort mais reste
à la traîne et tony blair souligner
quand même l'avancé de la pauvreté en
afrique
mais l'espoir qu'elle pourra finir can
be under jacques chirac lui aussi aurait
souhaité davantage mais il se veut
optimiste
il est plus facile de pousser une porte
entrouverte pour qu'elle s'ouvre
davantage que de se heurter à une porte
fermée qui ne veut pas sourire
au total le g8 aura donc trouver un
accord minimum sur le changement
climatique et manifester avec des
subventions accrues l'urgence de l'aide
à l'afrique avec l'ambition de
substituer partenariat assistance et à
la condition que les africains de leur
côté face les réformes nécessaires dans
le reste de l'actualité en france la
deuxième vague de départs en vacances
avec une journée classée rouge en ile de
france bison futé annonce un week-end
chargé
nathalie moisan guillaume bière
c'est la bonne surprise que les
parisiens n'attendait pas bison futé
avait vu rouge
mais alors du pic attendu 120 km de
bouchons seulement c'est un vendredi
ordinaire aux portes de paris
pas trop chaud jour 2
deux départs donc bastan clients on est
parti puis la somme avancée pour passer
des semaines de bonheur donc deux heures
de bouchon pour deux packs de bagnols
voilà
à revoir la carte verte
sur paris c'est beau sur la côte sauvage
en quête de soleil les franciliens sont
effectivement partis plus tôt que prévu
les touristes étrangers eux sont déjà là
a commencé de 3 jouant paris en
déshérence et maintenant reculer à
l'espagne mais reste nuit dans un hôtel
de belges gare de lyon cent mille
voyageurs attendus 128 tgv au départ et
sur les quais les regrets de ceux qui ne
partent pas je travaille je pas de
vacances
pour les autres le programme du week end
n'est pas compliqué boiteux plages et
les retardataires ont raison de se hâter
duval a retiré son but
demain est une journée rouge sur les
routes de france comme dans les gares
dans la sphère du bugaled breizh
chalutier qui avait coulé le 15 janvier
2004 avec cinq hommes à bord le juge
d'instruction chargé de l'enquêté a
évoqué aujourd'hui une force extérieure
comme cause possible du drame
le juge d'instruction qui a reçu des
familles n'a pas évoqué explicitement la
responsabilité d'un sous-marin mail
enquête va se poursuivre sur des
bâtiments militaires qui croisaient dans
la zone de naufrage plus six mois après
le drame de l'hôpital psychiatrique de
pau une infirmière et une aide soignante
avait été assassiné une reconstitution a
été organisée hier soir pour vérifier le
déroulement des faits et des actes du
meurtrier présumé roma dupuis un ancien
patient du centre avait reconnu les
faits début janvier
une première expertise psychiatrique
avait conclu qu'il était en partie
responsable de ses actes du côté du ciel
l'ouragan dennis arrive à cuba avec des
vents de 240 km/heure
après la jamaïque haïti l'ouragan menace
cuba puis la floride france musique 240
km/heure pour la vitesse des vents une
mer déchaînée qui grimpe à 4 mètres de
hauteur inondant le littoral
ce cyclone s'annonce particulièrement
costaud selon les météorologistes
en face de lui il trouvera à fidel
castro en personne le président cubain
prend les choses en main le voici dans
son rôle favori
le père de la nation rassurant ses
ouailles je ne pense pas qu'il y ait un
pays au monde qui possède une machinerie
pour protéger le peuple soit identique à
la nôtre
effronté à ce type de phénomène naturel
nous n'avons nous par la moindre visite
à cuba les évacuations se passe en
général dans le calme mais cette fois
fidel castro a fait monter la pression
il a prévenu que le cyclone de nice
allez je cite causé des dommages et des
grands le tour de france a rendu hommage
aujourd'hui aux victimes des attentats
de londres une minute de silence a été
observée au départ de la 7e étape une
étape remportée par l'australien robbie
mcewen lance amstrong conserve son
maillot jaune
nathanaël de rincquesen à béziers une
minute de silence ce matin le peloton du
tour a rendu hommage aux victimes des
attentats londonien dans une ambiance
pesante et sous une pluie battante les
coureurs prennent la route de carrefour
où 228 km l'occasion pour les allemands
de s'illustrer devant leur public
fabian wegmann ne se fait pas prier et
part seul à l'aventuré sur les bords de
la route
les allemands font honneur à la plus
grande course du monde
des kilomètres de spectateurs
enthousiastes le tour de points c'est
bien qu'il frôle le froid et la fatigue
ont finalement raison de vagues man
rejoint par le peloton peu après la
frontière entre le tout encore marqué
par une chute collective à 30 kilomètres
de l'arrivée
les corses ou le moral plonge news
d'hier à travers de la route
et comme si ça ne suffisait pas dans le
sprint final à 67 km heure au pro
l'encore la catastrope robbie mcewen lui
ne s'aperçoit de rien sinon qu'il
franchit la ligne en vainqueur
c'est le deuxième succès de l'australien
en trois jours sur le podium lance
amstrong enfile son maillot jaune et
constate avec plaisir que même sur les
terres de jan ullrich
sa popularité est exceptionnel le tour
de france n'a pas de frontières et puis
48 heures après la déception de
singapour où paris n'a pas été retenu
pour les jo 2012 la france confirme
quand même son attachement au jeu
puisque la ville d'annecy se porte
candidate pour l'organisation des jeux
olympiques d'hiver 2014
les collections de couture automne hiver
2005 2006 aujourd'hui jean paul gaultier
ses silhouettes inspirées des pays de
l'est
contrairement au luxe orientale chez
christian lacroix reportage estelle cola
thierry breton comme une espèce de tapis
c'est 2,3 me minuscule veste kazakh
bibis vous en se moquer pantalon moujik
à vent d'est à souffler cet après midi
chez jean paul gaultier
on sait badhus d'assez princesse la
porter haut et fort les couleurs d'une
turquie si personne ne veut ni peut-être
tout simplement parce que chez jean paul
gaultier
elle se vend bien
c'est merveilleux de faire de la couture
mais c'était pas non pire mais non c'est
extraordinaire ça pour rien au monde
si si la vie fait qu'il n'y a plus
besoin de la haute couture et de la
voilà mais en tous les cas c'est vrai
que ça fait partie de ma vision de la
vie de l'énergie et une salle pleine à
craquer complètement conquise par cette
couture race est épinglé et profits une
couture rendant hommage au savoir-faire
des ateliers qui trahissait la rigueur
d'un des maîtres français da luxe bien
vivants dont il détient le secret je
crois qu'il faut à la fois séduire une
femme qui a des codes assez académique
et en même temps se montrer sous son
jour le plus créatif on veut dire la
marque de passer récemment sous bannière
américaine n'a rien perdu de son face il
était assez facile de repérer d'ailleurs
les robes qui orneront les bons de
commande demain et c'est sous une pluie
deuxième lent qu'au final est venu
saluer un christian lacroix triomphant
musique pour terminer ce journal est une
belle affiche de ce soir à l'hippodrome
de longchamp pour trois jours de
solidarité au profit de la lutte contre
le sida
le festival solidays accueille patti
smith ou encore mickey 3d ou calogero
entre autres 48 personnes déjà présentes
sur le site pour cette série de concerts
quelques heures après la fermeture du g8
solidays est placée cette année sous le
signe de la solidarité avec l'afrique
c'est la fin de ce journal jean merci de
votre attention tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko puis le point route
valérie maurice 20h50 pj 1h20 le journal
de la nuit leur expliquer quand elle moi
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain dès 13h excellente soirée sur
france 2